schauen wir auf den teuer schock der
wird mittlerweile wirklich zum dauer
schock monatelang leugnete europas
oberste währungshüter in die chefin der
ezb christine lagarde ja den teuer
schock und jetzt ja jetzt waren sie
plötzlich davor dass er noch lange
anhält die zentrale aufgabe von
christine lagarde als oberste
währungshüter hin dass die inflation
nicht höher als zwei prozent ist aber im
juni da lagen die preise in deutschland
wir wissen es alle
7,6 prozent über vorjahr und der schock
der könnte noch lange anhalten was kommt
da noch auf uns darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit unserem er bildpolitik chef
jan schäfer hier bei uns im studio schön
dass du hier bist herzlich willkommen
man hat den eindruck christine lagarde
hat erst jetzt gemerkt was los ist oder
woher kommen jetzt plötzlich diese
warnungen ja das ist eigentlich an eine
grössere blamage kann es eigentlich gar
nicht geben für eine
ezb-präsident in oder für eine notenbank
chefin sie hat in der tat über monate
nicht zur kenntnis nehmen wollen was
sich da aufbaut und wir beide haben ja
bereits vor einem jahr davor gewarnt es
gab viele ökonomen auch in deutschland
die immer wieder gesagt haben achtung
achtung dieser anstieg der
inflationsraten und der war vor einem
jahr ja noch gar nicht so schlimm wie
wir ihn jetzt haben der wird eher länger
als kürzer dauern und da hat auch
christine lagarde immer gesagt nein nein
wartet ab wartet ab und hat eigentlich
die hände in den schoß gelegt und jetzt
hat sie man muss sagen eine kehrtwende
nicht um 180 grad sondern eher um 380
390 500 gramm der man das überhaupt
sagen kann genau vorgenommen und hat
gesagt plötzlich
die inflation der teuer schock diese
hohen inflationsraten die werden jetzt
erstmal auf dauer bleiben und das ist
also bemerkenswert ein größeres
armutszeugnis kann sich eine
notenbankchef in eigentlich nicht
ausstellen erst nicht die gefahr der
inflation zu erkennen und danach zu
sagen und jetzt bin ich quasi machtlos
und kann nichts dagegen tun das ist
wirklich die allergrößte blamage die
passieren kann erklärt nochmal den
einfluss den sie auch hart und den
einfluss der ezb und ja was man jetzt
eigentlich auch noch tun kann also ich
meine hier zu entlassen wie möglich eine
lösung aber das kann ja auch nicht dass
maß aller dinge sein dann genau
entlassen geht sowieso nichts gewählt
oder hat diesen posten inne für sieben
jahre von daher ist sie da eigentlich
erst mal relativ sicher auf diesem
posten was genau das ist die vollkommen
berechtigte frage hat eigentlich
christine lagarde als chefin der
europäischen zentralbank mit unserem
geld mit der inflation zu tun sehr sehr
viel die europäische zentralbank ist
diejenige bank die das geld heraus gibt
die den euro herausgibt die münzen und
die scheine und die eine einzige aufgabe
hat nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass das
geld was wir alle haben stabil ist dass
der geldwert stabiles dass es keine
inflation gibt es gibt ein ziel ein
inflationsziel von zwei prozent kann man
sagen es auch schon zu hoch wie auch
immer das ist das ziel das ziel darf
nicht überschritten werden dieses ziel
hat sich die europäische zentralbank
gegeben und wir haben es auch gerade
gehört die inflation liegt jetzt bei 7,6
prozent sie lag schon aber fast acht
prozent hier in deutschland im euroraum
liegt sie ungefähr ähnlich hoch und wir
sehen dass die europäische zentralbank
also ihr eigentliches ziel katastrophal
verfehlt weil sie eine fast viermal so
hohe inflation mittlerweile beherrschen
muss als eigentlich zulässig wäre wie
gesagt die erste aufgabe der
europäischen zentralbank ist
inflationsbekämpfung da kann die politik
gar nicht so viel machen dass es vor
allem die aufgabe der notenbank und wie
macht sie das das kann sie
beispielsweise über zinserhöhungen dann
tun dasselbe ist jetzt nicht großartig
passiert wir schauen also in unserem
geldbeutel rein und sehen alles wird
teurer das benzin das gas die kleidung
die lebensmittel und jetzt kriegen wir
die warnung das geht auch noch so weiter
ganz kurzfristige einschätzung jetzt
noch von dir worauf haben wir uns da
alle wir verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher wir beginnen und bürger
einzustellen wir haben uns auf viele
viele monate möglicherweise sogar jahre
von deutlich steigenden preisen
einzustellen das hat verschiedene
ursachen hat natürlich auch mit dem
ukraine krieg zu tun hat auch mit dem
kommt mit der korona pandemie zu tun
stichwort lieferketten hat natürlich
auch damit zu tun dass löhne jetzt auch
kräftig steigen es gibt heute morgen
eine umfrage des ifo instituts aus
münchen bei
lebensmittelherstellern oder generell im
handel auch und da ist davon auszugehen
dass auch in den nächsten monaten ist
deutliche erhöhungen bei den
lebensmittelpreisen geben wird meine
schätzung ist der
in diesem jahr mit der höchsten
inflationsrate weise wird der september
sein also das ist der neuer shop monat
nummer eins dann warum unter anderem
weil dann auch der tank rabatt und auch
das 9 euro ticket auslaufen das treibt
natürlich dann die preise noch mal
wieder nach oben